[Music]
in 1987 tens of thousands of people
gathered in Saudi Arabia for the annual
Hajj pilgrimage but what started out as
a celebration led to a health crisis
just a few days after the pilgrimage
more than 2,000 cases of meningitis
broke out spreading across Saudi Arabia
and the rest of the world the outbreak
was so fierce that it was believed to
have sparked a wave of deadly meningitis
epidemics that ultimately infected tens
of thousands of people worldwide
meningitis is the inflammation of the
meninges three tissue layers responsible
for protecting the brain and spinal cord
what makes meningitis so dangerous
compared to other diseases is the sheer
speed with which it invades a person's
body in the worst cases it causes death
within a day fortunately that's rare for
patients who receive early medical
treatment the disease primarily comes in
three forms fungal viral and bacterial
the last being the most deadly by far
and what will focus on people usually
contract bacterial meningitis by
breathing in tiny particles of mucus and
saliva that spray into the air when an
infected person sneezes or coughs it can
also be transmitted through kissing or
sharing cigarettes toothbrushes or
utensils some people can be infected and
carry the disease without showing
symptoms or getting sick which helps the
disease spread quickly to others once
the bacteria enter the nose mouth and
throat they cross the surrounding
membranes and enter the bloodstream from
there bacteria have rapid access to the
body's tissues including a membrane
called the blood-brain barrier this is
made of a tight mesh of cells which
separate blood vessels from the brain
and block everything except for a
specific set of particles include
water molecules and some gases but in
ways that scientists are still trying to
understand meningitis bacteria can trick
the barrier into letting them through
inside the brain the bacteria swiftly
infect the meninges this triggers
inflammation as the body's immune
response kicks into overdrive bringing
on fever and intense headaches as
swelling in the meninges worsens the
neck begins to stiffen swelling in the
brain disrupts its normal function
causing symptoms like hearing loss and
extreme light sensitivity as pressure
increases in the cranium it may also
make the person confused one of the
hallmarks of the disease a few hours in
the rapidly multiplying bacteria start
to release toxins leading to septicemia
also known as blood poisoning this
breaks down blood vessels letting blood
seep out and form what starts out
looking like a rash and evolves into big
discolored blots beneath the skin at the
same time those toxins burn through
oxygen in the blood reducing the amount
that gets to major organs like the lungs
and kidneys that increases the chance of
organs shut down and alongside spreading
septicemia threatens death that all
sounds scary but doctors are so good at
treating meningitis that a visit to the
hospital can drastically reduce an
adult's risk of dying from it the longer
it's left untreated though the more
likely it will lead to lasting damage
if declining oxygen levels cause cell
death in extreme parts of the body like
fingers toes arms and legs the risk of
amputation goes up and if bacterial
toxins accumulated in the brain and
trigger cell death meningitis could also
cause long-term brain damage and memory
loss so fast treatment or better yet
prevention is critical that's why most
countries have vaccines that defend
against the disease in its deadliest
forms those are usually given to the
people who are most at risk like young
children people with weak immune systems
who can gather in large groups where an
outbreak of meningitis could potentially
happen in addition to those gatherings
meningitis is most common in a region
called the meningitis belt that
stretches across Africa though cases do
happen all over the world if you're
concerned that you or someone you know
may have meningitis get to the doctor as
soon as possible
quick action could save your life find
out more about how vaccines save lives
by watching this video
[Music]